en partiel est subi 60% d'entre ces
salariés souhaitent une augmentation de
leur temps de travail soit 29 mille
personnes et parmi les 40 % restants
nombre d'entre eux nombre d'entre elles
s'autocensurent considérant qu'elles
n'ont peu de rire c'est moyenne se
cachent aussi de gros écarts les femmes
non diplômées les employés et les femmes
étrangères subissent plus souvent que
les autres le temps partiel le pic de la
proportion des femmes à temps partiel se
situant entre 35 et 44 ans selon une
étude du conseil économique et social
les secteurs d'activité les plus touchés
sont les services aux entreprises et des
services aux personnes
le nettoyage la distribution le commerce
l'hôtellerie restauration mais également
les collectivités locales
côté salaires 50 % des salariés à temps
partiel percevrait moins de 800 euros
or l'ensemble des droits sociaux la
retraite bien sûr mais aussi les
indemnités journalières dont le congé
maternité sont calculées sur cette base
et selon des données insee de 2009 33 %
des foyers monoparentaux environ 1
million 600 mille hommes essentiellement
des femmes avec enfants disposent de
revenus inférieurs au seuil de pauvreté
parmi les ailes des femmes actives
souvent victimes de bas salaires des
temps partiels contraints morcelé et peu
rémunérés on comprend alors comment les
femmes particulièrement celles qui
assument seules les charges de leurs
enfants forment la catégorie des
personnes les plus pauvres de notre pays
ces données sont connues mais il faut
maintenant engager des changements
concrets
ces questions sont à des articulations
de plusieurs ministères dont le vôtre
madame la ministre le droit des femmes
et je souhaiterais savoir comment vous
vous engagez comment vous allez suivre
ce chantier transversale attendu par une
grande partie de la population qui
travaille
mais qui ne s'en sort pas merci je vous
remercie chers collègues
pour la réponse la parole est à madame
najat vallaud belkacem ministre des
droits des femmes porte parole du
gouvernement
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice meunier merci de mettre le
doigt sur un sujet absolument crucial
lorsqu'on s'intéresse à l'égalité
professionnelle et aux réponses à
apporter aux écarts toujours aussi
important dans notre pays
c'est un sujet absolument crucial que le
temps partiel et en particulier le temps
partiel subi dans lequel sont repris sur
représentés vous l'avez dit les femmes
c'est un sujet qui a été longtemps
oubliés des politiques publiques ça fait
partie de ces angles morts on ne sait
pas suffisamment intéressé à la question
de la sur représentation des femmes dans
certaines filières d'activités
caractérisé par leur précarité comme
vous l'avez dit ou encore de cette
présence dans le temps partiel or qui
dit temps partiel évidemment dit
rémunération partiel dit d'ailleurs
cotisations partiel pour la retraite et
donc le triple peine d'une certaine
façon
aujourd'hui quand vous regardez l'écart
moyen de rémunération entre les hommes
et les femmes vous prenez conscience que
la moitié de cet écart près de 14 %
s'explique par le recours au temps
partiel chez les femmes qui les met dans
une situation de grande précarité
et cette situation n'a cessé de se
dégrader
vous savez la france ne connaissait
quasiment pas le temps partiel au début
des années 80 c'était un million et demi
de femmes qui étaient embauchés sous
cette forme en 1981 et trente ans plus
tard elles sont quasiment 4 millions 3,7
millions soit un tiers de l'emploi
féminin alors il est toujours
intéressant de regarder comment d'autres
pays entre autour de nous ont pris à
bras le corps cette problématique
je crois que nous avons en france une
spécificité qui est notamment liée à
l'inégalé répartition des tâches
domestiques entre les hommes et les
femmes sur laquelle il va falloir
travailler une fois pour toutes
pour ce qui est je reviendrai plus tard
sur cette inégale répartition des tâches
pour ce qui est du temps partiel en
particulier nous avons décidé avec les
partenaires sociaux réunis dans la
grande conférence sociale de juillet
dernier que c'était un sujet sur lequel
ils pouvaient négocier ils s'y sont
engagés dès le 21 septembre dernier ils
doivent nous remettre leurs conclusions
au mois de mars prochain avant le 8 mars
se sont ils engagés pour réussir à la
fois mieux protéger ces femmes en temps
partiel notamment celles d'entre elles
qui sont en très petit temps partiel et
qui n'ont pas accès à un certain nombre
de droits sociaux et notamment les
indemnités journalières donc meilleure
protection pour aussi et bien
sanctionner les entreprises qui abusent
dans le recours au temps partiel car on
sait que les abus existent pour enfin
favoriser plus que ça n'est le cas
aujourd'hui le passage du temps partiel
au temps complet
et là encore un certain nombre de
dispositions législatives pourront être
prises dans ce sens sachez que sans
attendre les conclusions des partenaires
sociaux nous organiserons le 19 novembre
prochain
ce que nous appelons une conférence de
progrès sur le temps partiel qui sur
plusieurs branches cette problématique
et d'y apporter déjà quelques réponses
je vous remercie vous disposez d'une
minute pour la réplique
merci madame la ministre pour ces
éléments de réponse
et pour poursuivre je souhaiterais aussi
de dire qu' il serait intéressant de ne
pas forcément rester autocentrée sur ces
questions là en france mais regardée
aussi niveau de l'europe
et là je voudrais saluer donc
l'expression publique que vous avez
exprimé au nom de la france par le
projet de directive européenne soutenue
par madame viviane reding qui renforce
le nombre de femmes dans les conseils
d'administration des entreprises
j'y vois là aussi un engagement de
changement pour nous et pour le bon
nombre de nos concitoyens et
concitoyennes je vous remercie
je vous remercie également chers
collègues
la parole est maintenant à madame
brigitte gonthier maurin pour le groupe
communiste républicain et citoyen merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
chers collègues nous avons des
préoccupations partagées
oui le temps partiel un genre et il est
féminin or nous savons que ce temps
partiel est un paramètre clé des
inégalités salariales et
professionnelles
il pèse en effet pour un peu plus d'un
tiers dans un écart entre les salaires
des femmes et ceux des hommes qu'on
évalue à près de 27 %
ce n'est pas seulement un angle mort le
temps partiel s'est massivement
développée au cours des vingt dernières
années sous l'impulsion de politiques
qui l'ont rendu attractif pour les
employeurs par des abattements de
cotisations sociales et parce qu'il
permettait davantage de flexibilité dans
la gestion de la main d'oeuvre souvent
présentée comme un moyen de permettre
une meilleure articulation entre vie
professionnelle et vie personnelle
le temps partiel est dans la réalité
bien davantage subi que choisi avec ses
horaires morcelé ses délais de
prévenance très court son régime de
coupure
il ne facilite pas l'articulation entre
les différents temps de vie s'applique
en outre à des emplois peu qualifiés et
par conséquent mal rémunérés il vient
gonfler des cohortes de femmes
travailleuses pauvres
il faut donc revoir son encadrement
plusieurs pistes ont été proposées à la
délégation aux droits des femmes dans le
cadre des auditions cal-maine cette
année sur le thème femmes et travail
majoration salariale pour l'ensemble des
heures complémentaires effectuées revise
révision au niveau des exonérations
sociales condition de réversibilité du
temps partiel vers le temple un accès à
la formation aux droits sociaux
amélioration par un meilleur encadrement
de la durée des intervalles prix entre
les prises de poste ou des délais de
prévenance la négociation collective que
sur certains de ces points apporter des
améliorations significatives mais
d'autres appellent une révision du cadre
législatif
je souhaiterais madame la ministre que
vous nous indiquez la feuille de route
du gouvernement vous l'avez en partie
entamée à l'instant mais peut-être
pourrez-vous développer plus avant ce
qui nous a été déjà dit
sur un sujet qui intéresse un très grand
nombre de nos compatriotes qui compte
parmi les plus touchés par la précarité
et la pauvreté
merci pour la réponse vous avez la
parole madame la ministre
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice
je crois que ça n'est pas un hasard
un hasard si vous posez toutes les deux
une question sur le temps partiel c'est
que vous avez conscience en effet que
c'est l'un des motifs de précarité dans
la vie économique dans le monde du
travail les plus importants des femmes
aujourd'hui est que ce cette situation
est particulièrement difficile à vivre
en effet pour celles d'entre elles qui
sont en plus à la tête de familles
monoparentales car on constate de fait
que souvent les deux sont liés or c'est
vrai qu'il est un argument qui est
souvent utilisée par ceux qui cherchent
à minimiser cette problématique du temps
partiel subi qui est mais beaucoup du
temps partiel est un temps partiel
choisi notamment pour des raisons de
meilleure articulation entre la vie
professionnelle et la vie personnelle
pour pouvoir gérer le foyer pour dire
les choses rapidement
vous avez raison et il faudra le faire
aux efforts de souligner que très
souvent le temps partiel tel qu'il
existe aujourd'hui pour les femmes est
un temps partiel qui les empêche d'avoir
une vie personnelle les empêche d'avoir
une vie familiale parce que c'est un
temps partiel qui s'accompagne
d'horaires atypiques imprévisible et qui
les fait souffrir et les tiraille en
réalité puisqu'il ne leur permet de
répondre à cette articulation des temps
alors oui je vous suis sur la nécessité
en effet de sanctionner les entreprises
qui abusent c'est vrai que ces dernières
décennies on a beaucoup laissé les
entreprises recourir avec un certain
nombre davantage à ce type de temps et
notamment le statut des heures
complémentaires est une vraie difficulté
il faudra le re le revaloriser faire en
sorte que ces heures soit considéré un
peu comme les heures supplémentaires du
temps plein tout simplement et c'est
l'un des sujets sur lequel le travail
donc les partenaires sociaux que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure la question de
la meilleure prévisibilité des horaires
et
et d'une plus grande amplitude de ces
horaires se pose également tout comme se
pose la question peut-être d'un nombre
minimal d'heures de travail puisque je
le disais tout à l'heure alors ce taux
minimal ce nombre d'heures minimal sera
sans doute avoir branche par branche car
il est impossible de plaquer une même
solution pour l'ensemble des branches
professionnelles qui ne sont pas dans la
même situation mais est ce qui n'est
plus possible c'est d'avoir en effet un
temps si petit qu'il ne donne pas accès
à certains droits sociaux
les huit partenaires sociaux je le
disais sont invités à négocier sur le
sujet ça ne veut pas dire que l'état se
décharge de ses responsabilités entend
donc bien comme sur l'ensemble des
négociations dont ont été saisis les
partenaires sociaux s'ils n'arrivent pas
à se mettre d'accord sur ces sujets qui
nous semblent fondamentaux évidemment
l'état prendra ses responsabilités et
c'est pour ça que je le disais tout à
l'heure mais j'ai pas vraiment le temps
de développer sans attendre en effet le
19 novembre prochain un moment important
qui est cette conférence de progrès sur
le temps partiel pendant laquelle nous
aborderons les pratiques de toutes ces
entreprises et de toutes ses branches
d'activité qui recourent fortement au
temps partiel mais les pratiques aussi
des donneurs d'ordres parce que prenez
une branche comme la propreté
typiquement certes c'est parce que
l'entreprise va pratiquer des horaires
atypiques qu'ils existeront mais c'est
aussi parce que les donneurs d'ordres
parfois ce sont des collectivités
locales ou l'état lui-même une
personnalité publique qui vont réclamer
que les agents de propreté viennent très
tôt le matin avant que les agents
n'arrive et ça il faut y mettre un terme
et donc ça relève de la responsabilité
aussi bien de l'employeur directement
je sais que le temps est court pour la
réplique
la parole est à madame laurence cohen
oui merci beaucoup madame la ministre
parce que effectivement je crois que ces
emplois à temps partiel se sont
développés et ont été facteur de
généraliser la précarisation dans le
monde du travail et sont les femmes qui
ont été les qui en ont été les premières
victimes
je crois que c'est très important ce que
vous venez de souligner c'est à dire
qu'effectivement il ya des prérogatives
des partenaires sociaux besoin de
négociations mais il ya le rôle
fondamental de l'état parce que
l'égalité professionnelle entre les
femmes et les hommes relève du
législatif et s'est inscrit dans la
constitution donc c'est à nous de le
faire appliquer donc c'est la première
chose qui me semble très importante a
redonné et la deuxième chose je crois
que concernant justement ce ce temps
partiel qui ne fait que se développer
il faudrait que voir faire en sorte que
les entreprises puissent avoir des
charges patronales qui soit équivalente
quand elle utilise des temps plein ou
des temps partiels et je parle
évidemment de grosses entreprises qui en
abusent
voilà merci je vaux merci chers
collègues
la parole est maintenant à madame aline
archimbaud pour le groupe écologiste
monsieur le président madame la ministre
et chers collègues nous le savons
l'écart de salaire entre les femmes et
les hommes stagne depuis le dé le milieu
des années 1990 et reste un niveau de
compétence de diplômes et de
responsabilité égale au niveau très
élevé est inadmissible en moyenne de 27%
les femmes représentent 83% les emplois
à temps partiel et occupe 60 % des
postes en cdd
la question du traitement de la
parentalité dans le contexte
professionnel est central dans la lutte
contre les inégalités entre les hommes
et les femmes
car si seulement 6% des hommes vivent un
changement dans leur situation
professionnelle lors de l'arrivée d'un
enfant
c'est le cas pour près de 40% des femmes
il faudrait donc inciter les hommes à
investir la sphère privée
afin que les femmes puissent investir la
sphère publique et professionnelle
davantage les ajustements entre travail
et vie familiale incombe majoritairement
aux femmes et cela influe sur leur
parcours professionnel
ainsi la discontinuité des carrières des
femmes s'explique notamment par le fait
qu'elle assume 80% des tâches
domestiques ce qui représente sur une
année dix neuf semaines de travail en
plus pour aider leurs salariés à mieux
articuler vie professionnelle et vie
familiale plusieurs types de mesures
sont essentiellement mise en oeuvre par
les entreprises prestations en nature
avantages financiers parfois et quelques
mesures de souplesse horaire madame la
ministre
comment comptez vous encourager les
entreprises à mieux prendre en charge la
parentalité
que pensez-vous en particulier et par
exemple de la proposition faite par un
rapport de l'inspection générale des
affaires sociales de réformer le congé
de maternité actuellement de 16 semaines
en le découpant en un congé de maternité
de douze semaines pour la mer suivie de
quatre semaines de congés pour l'accueil
de l'enfant qui serait pour le père et
pour la mer non fractionnable et non
transférable entre les deux parents ceci
permettrait au père de s'impliquer
davantage dans la vie domestique et
familial et cela elle serait un
véritable partage de la responsabilité
parentale
madame najat vallaud belkacem unissent
des droits des femmes porte-parole du
gouvernement vous avez la parole pour la
réponse
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice archimbaud merci pour cette
question qui me permet du coup de
compléter vous propose de tout à l'heure
puisque je disais que beaucoup de choses
étaient liés évidemment à l'inégalé
répartition des tâches à la maison je
commencerai peut-être par dire que ce
qui m'amuse beaucoup c'est que depuis
que je suis donc dans ce ministère en
droit des deux en charge des droits des
femmes et que je discute notamment avec
les plus jeunes générations de ces
inégalités persistantes entre les hommes
et les femmes
on a tendance à me répondre mais tu sais
les choses s'améliorent quand même moi
dans mon couple nous qui sommes
trentenaire c'est très différent de nos
aînés et il ya une forme d'égalité dans
la répartition des tâches est en fait je
vous invite pour tous ceux qui croient
encore à cela que je vous invite à
prendre connaissance de toutes les
études sur le sujet qui démontre que
comme vous l'avez vous même souligné si
en effet au début de la formation du
couple vous avez une certaine égalité
dans la répartition des tâches dès
qu'arrivent les enfants dès qu'arrivent
les enfants et notamment le troisième
des enfants eh bien on se retrouve avec
le 80% des tâches effectuées par les
femmes est d'ailleurs il ya un chiffre
qui est très intéressant pour illustrer
ce que je viens de dire c'est le taux
d'activité des femmes qui ont deux
enfants dont un de moins de 3 ans donc
deux enfants dont un en bas âge ce taux
d'activité est de 67% contre 97 % pour
les hommes
donc on voit bien que quand même ça ça
pose un certain nombre de difficultés
alors au moment de la conférence sociale
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure avec les
partenaires sociaux on a essayé de se
mettre d'accord sur ces questions de
congés familiaux et on a abouti au moins
trois principes sur lesquels je veux
revenir parce que ils répondront à vos
questions le premier c'est qu'il me
semble absolument essentiel de maintenir
et de sanctuary zay le congé maternité
qui est un congé spécifique pour la mère
de 16 semaines dont huit semaines
obligatoires comme c'est prévu dans le
droit actuel d'ailleurs j'en profite
pour dire que nous prenons un certain
nombre d'initiatives pour relancer les
négociations sur la directive européenne
congé maternité dont vous savez qu'elle
est bloquée au niveau communautaire et
nous
lyon qu'elle soit relancé je pense aussi
que le retour des femmes de leur congé
maternité pourrait sans doute être plus
protégés qu'il ne l'est actuellement
puisque dans le droit actuel vous savez
que les femmes pendant quatre semaines
ne peuvent pas se faire licencier quatre
semaines après leur retour de congé
maternité sans doute pourrions nous
élargir un petit peu ce délai après le
retour c'est un délai qui me semble trop
court
deuxième chose importante il faut
inciter davantage les hommes à prendre
le congé paternité qui ne le font
aujourd'hui
tous les moyens seront les bons
incitations faut-il aller jusqu à
l'obligation c'est une question que nous
nous posons sérieusement mais en tout
cas il faut les inciter troisième
principe sur lequel nous nous sommes
arrêtés
le congé parental celui de longue durée
qui donc tu peux aller jusqu'à trois ans
et pose des difficultés parce qu'ils
constituent une trappe à inactivité à
certains égards pour les femmes qui se
retrouvent éloigner trop durablement du
marché du travail qui ont du mal à y
revenir
comment faire pour mieux accompagner ces
femmes pendant leur congé parental par
le biais de formations notamment c'est
ce que nous expérimentons dans certaines
régions
comment faire surtout pour que les
hommes prennent une partie de ce congé
parental c'est ce que nous avons demandé
aux partenaires et je pense que je
terminerais ma réponse à l'occasion
d'une autre question mais vous voyez que
tous ces sujets sont évidemment en
discussions mais que tous ces sujets
sont étroitement liées aussi au nombre
de places d'accueil collectif que nous
pourrons créer pour l'accueil des jeunes
enfants
ça passe par les crèches ça passe par
les crèches en entreprise ou
interentreprises et puis les assistantes
maternelles
il ya madame aline archimbaud pour la
réponse je vous remercie de votre
intérieur de votre réponse madame la
ministre je pense en effet compte tenu
de la situation que nous connaissons et
vous avez à nouveau souligné des
inégalités qui persistent importante il
faut encourager les
les dispositifs qui permettent que les
femmes et les hommes aient la même
chance parce que je pense que c'est une
chance de développer à la fois leur vie
professionnelle de vivre leur vie
familiale de manière équilibrée et
d'élever leurs enfants de manière
partagée c'est je crois le sens des
propositions qui sont faites sans
toucher de fait aux seize semaines de
congé de maternité simplement le
complément qui est proposé c'est
d'ajouter en fait quinze jours au onze
jours de congé qui existe déjà pour les
pères de façon à ce qu'on est pour
chacun des deux un mois et je pense que
sur le plan aussi bien culturelles des
mentalités que que de la qualité de la
vie dans les entreprises les docks sur
un plan plus structurel nous aurions
tous et toutes et grant lui et chers
collègues je souhaiterais faire d'abord
un petit rappel essayé de respecter vos
temps de parole sinon vos nos collègues
ne pourront pas bénéficier d'un du temps
d'antenne qui aurait pu leur être
accordé la parole est maintenant à
madame françoise laborde pour le groupe
de rassemblement du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
c'est notamment grâce à yvette roudy en
1983 que la bataille législative contre
les inégalités professionnelles a été
engagée dans notre pays
et après 26 ans nous sommes ravis
d'avoir avec vous un ministère de plein
exercice à ce stade multiplier les
dispositifs législatifs contraignant ou
incitatif n'est sans doute plus le plus
urgent il faudrait déjà appliquée
l'existant les efforts déployés n'ont
pas suffi à briser le plafond de verre
cet ensemble d'obstacles qui empêche les
femmes d'accéder aux plus hautes
responsabilités professionnelles
comment lever les freins qui
maintiennent une représentation social
inégalitaire du rôle des femmes dans
notre pays à cette question louis maurin
directeur de l'observatoire des
inégalités répond au moment de l'arrivée
dans le monde de travail
il est déjà trop tard je partage son
diagnostic
le concours de l'entrée à l'ena illustre
cette discrimination positive en faveur
des hommes entre 2006 et 2010 45 5% des
candidats aux concours externes étaient
des femmes
alors qu'après le grand oral elle ne
formaient plus que 34 5 % des admis une
ancienne présidente du jury tente une
explication
les garçons sont des à l'école primaire
plus couramment interrogés et mis en
confiance à l'oral que les petites
filles invitées à se tenir discrètement
dans la réserve
madame la ministre sont bien les
stéréotypes qui détermine la
représentation sociale du rôle des
femmes pour les faire tomber nous devons
les combattre à la source et inculquer à
tous les enfants
le principe d'égalité entre les filles
et les garçons
le chantier de refondation lancé par le
ministre de l'éducation nationale en est
une formidable occasion de grands axes
doivent être privilégiés pour y réussir
la refonte complète du parcours
d'orientation des élèves tout au long de
la scolarité et l'introduction d'un
module pédagogique spécifique dans le
cursus de formation des enseignants
c'est pourquoi madame la ministre avec
les membres du groupe rdse
je vous demande quelles propositions
concrètes vous comptez faire au ministre
de l'éducation nationale pour aller en
ce sens vous avez la parole madame la
ministre
si monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice laborde
merci pour cette question qui me donne
l'occasion de revenir en effet sur le
travail que nous avons d'ores et déjà
entrepris avec vincent peillon et le
ministère de l'éducation nationale
puisque je vais évidemment dans le sens
de votre diagnostic les choses
commencent dès le plus jeune âge et
c'est donc dès le plus jeune âge qu'il
faut agir sur elle qu'il faut agir sur
les mentalités les stéréotypes les
représentations qui cantonne les femmes
et les hommes les filles et les garçons
à des rôles bien spécifique et souvent
inégalitaire donc dès le plus jeune âge
il s'agit non pas de remettre en cause
le fait qu'une fille est une fille et un
garçon est un garçon oui il ya une
différence en effet entre les sexes mais
cette différence j'allais dire
physiologique n'est pas une raison à
créer des inégalités
qui vont trop souvent de pair
aujourd'hui avec ladite différence et en
particulier il n'y a pas de raison dès
le plus jeune âge donne à prendre aux
petites filles a développé que certaines
qualités ou de ne leur apprendre à rêver
que de certaines professions et de
réduire de restreindre ainsi leur panel
de perspectives et de réflexion qui est
de fait bien plus contraints que celui
des hommes on le voit notamment au
moment de l'orientation camps se
dessinent les destins professionnels et
on le retrouve plus tard lorsque la
moitié des femmes actives sont
finalement concentré sur douze familles
professionnelles sur 87 en tout donc il
ya quand même une difficulté qu'il nous
faut prendre à bras le corps apprendre
l'égalité ça se fait ça se fait pour les
enseignants car ça n'a rien de simple
que de déconstruire les stéréotypes avec
lesquels on vit toute la journée dans la
formation des enseignants qui sera prévu
dans la loi rénovation de l'école il y
aura donc ce module de déconstruction
des stéréotypes pour les enseignants
pour tous les personnels d'orientation
de direction des établissements
scolaires aussi et puis l'égalité il
faut la prendre aussi aux élèves et ce
dès le plus jeune âge dès la crèche moi
j'aime beaucoup l'expérimentation de la
crèche bourdarias à saint-ouen traiter
les petits garçons et petites filles de
la même manière leur apprendre à jouer
avec les mêmes jeux un peu plus tard au
collège au lycée parler d'éducation à la
sexualité faire l'égalité dans les faits
et pas simplement dans la loi merci je
remercie madame la ministre pour la
réplique madame françoise laborde nadhem
la mini je vous remercie et en effet je
n'avais pas parlé dans le temps qui
m'était imparti de la petite enfance
mais je pense que nous sommes d'accord
pour dire que le changement de mentalité
ne sera possible que si la bonne
éducation j'entends par là celle qui
permet de lutter contre les stéréotypes
de genre ne se fait au départ dans la
famille à la crèche et la nourrice et
bien sûr après l'école maternelle prend
le relais je vous remercie beaucoup
je vous remercie chers collègues la
parole est maintenant à madame chantal
jouanno pour le groupe union pour un
mouvement populaire
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues ma question
s'inscrit dans les pas de mes
prédécesseurs re je remarque d'ailleurs
qu'il n'ya que des femmes qui posent des
questions et que nous constatons tout
que
les inégalités persistent en matière
d'égalité salariale d'emplois précaires
d'accession à des postes de
responsabilité dans les entreprises et
de répartition des tâches est évidemment
comme l'a dit mama prédécesseurs tout à
l'heure tous ceux ci repose sur un
problème de stéréotypes inculqué dès le
plus jeune âge et je voudrais revenir
sur un sujet qui me tient à coeur vous
le savez c'est celui de l'hyper
sexualisation des enfants
l'hyper sexualisation des enfants
renvoie un problème pas seulement les
petites lolitas qui pourrait apparaître
comme un jeu qui n'est pas dangereux
mais plus lourdement à une question de
société
certes il ya des problèmes individuels
psycho affectif qui peuvent se poser
mais surtout ce n'est pas la peine
demain de vouloir parler d'égalité
salariale si nous ne faisons rien contre
ces différents stéréotypes qui sont à
l'école qui sont surtout dans les jeux
vidéo dans les dessins animés dans les
clips vidéo dans les magazines pour pour
jeunes filles et nous avions fait des
propositions extrêmement précise
d'ailleurs qu'on avait beaucoup discuté
au sein de la délégation aux droits des
femmes sur l'hypersexualisation non pas
comme sujet vraiment hyper sexualisation
mais vraiment dans l'optique de lutter
contre les inégalités qui s'accumulent
que dès le plus jeune le plus jeune âge
donc j'aimerais savoir madame la
ministre si vous comptez reprendre ses
propositions
que ce soient celles qui viennent d'être
évoqués sur la nécessité d' assez crus
et les livres scolaires et l'éducation
dans son ensemble de permettre une
orientation plus équilibrée entre les
garçons et les filles mais aussi
peut-être de mettre un terme aux excès
que sont les concours de mini miss qui
d'ailleurs n'existe pas au masculin et
je vous remercie
merci vous avez la parole madame la
ministre pour la réponse merci monsieur
le président merci madame la sénatrice
jouanno je regardais le chronomètre
parce que donc quand vous parlez moins
longtemps je récupère vos deux minutes à
la fin vaut deux secondes deux secondes
bon je vais plus vite donc je sais que
c'est un sujet en effet
qui vous préoccupe et à raison que cette
question de l'hypersexualisation des
petites filles j'ai évidemment pris
connaissance et je vous remercie de me
l'avoir adressé du rapport que vous avez
y est remis à madame bachelot sur cette
question la situation que vous dénoncez
c'est à la fois si je devais résumer
celle de l'érotisation du corps des
jeunes filles mais c'est aussi au fond
le fait pour ces jeunes filles d'adopter
des comportements d'adulte sans repères
et qui peuvent être évidemment
dévastateur dans leur éducation dans
dans les années qui suivent dévastateur
d'ailleurs cette hyper sexualisation
aussi bien pour les petites filles que
pour les petits garçons je pense que
c'est important à souligner parce que
des garçons aussi on attend des choses
qu'ils ont parfois du mal des exigences
qu'ils ont parfois du mal à remplir on
attend d'eux une certaine virilité
certains de clichés autour de la
domination et quand ils ne sont pas cela
et bien ils en souffrent aussi et le
malaise est là
donc vous avez dans votre rapport
formulé un certain nombre de
recommandations qui associe à la fois
des mesures d'interdiction et puis des
mesures de d'information et de
sensibilisation sachez que nous sommes
en train d'expertiser juridiquement la
question de l'interdiction donc nous en
reparlerons très prochainement avec vous
et en particulier en effet de ces
concours de beauté qui nous pose parfois
des difficultés mais surtout ce que dit
votre rapport au fond c'est ce que nous
disions à l'instant c'est la nécessité
pour ces enfants d'être éduqué à la
sexualité pour dire les choses de façon
large mais quand anton par éducation à
la sexualité c'est en réalité éducation
au respect à l'égalité des sexes à la
dignité
ce qui manque cruellement aujourd'hui à
l'école vous savez que la loi de 2001
d'imposer dans tous les établissements
scolaires elle n'est pas appliquée il
faudra le faire ce qui manque
cruellement aujourd'hui aussi c'est ce
sont des messages positifs sur ces
sujets dans les médias dans la publicité
j'ai relevé une chose je terminerai par
là c'est que les agences de régulation
qu'il s'agisse du csa de la rp ou de
l'arcep souvent vont regarder ce sujet à
travers la lorgnette de la dignité et
n'arrêteront les images que si elle
estime qu' elle porte atteinte à la
dignité
tu es des femmes il faut désormais
qu'elle les regarde sous la lorgnette du
sexisme et la véhicule à sion des
stéréotypes et certaines images doivent
être arrêtés simplement parce qu'elles
véhiculent des stéréotypes et notamment
ceux de la domination masculine sur les
corps des femmes et pas parce qu'elle
irait jusqu'à porter atteinte à la
dignité
voilà un sujet sur lequel nous
travaillons mais nous pourrons en
discuter ensemble
madame jouanno pour la réplique merci
monsieur le président effectivement
alors vous pouvez vous appuyer sur la
charte qui avait été faite par roselyne
bachelot d'ailleurs sur l'image des
femmes dans les médias qui visait à
faire bouger l'ensemble des instances de
régulation ce n'est pas toujours très
simple et vraiment je aujourd'hui nous
ne sommes pas touchés massivement france
par ce problème d'hypersexualisation
mais il n'y a aucune barrière qui
résistera durablement à ces stratégies
marketing la grande bretagne en a fait
une priorité nationale portée par le
premier ministre lui-même
donc je pense que c'est notre
responsabilité collective de ne pas
enterrer sujet je vous remercie la
parole est maintenant à madame catherine
morin desailly pour le groupe de l'union
centriste et républicaine
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre cheikh collègues je souhaite
profiter de cette séance nous met en
lumière un autre problème qui est celui
de la faible représentation des femmes
dans le secteur culturel et notamment
dans celui du spectacle vivant
en 2005 le ministre donne lieu de
s'étonner il disait est il normal que
sur les 38 directeurs de centres
dramatiques nationaux et régionaux on ne
compte que trois femmes
qu'en est il aujourd'hui quelques
chiffres pour illustrer mon propos
4 % des maisons d'opéra et 9% des
centres dramatiques sont dirigées par
des femmes
elle occupe 18 % des postes dirigeants
de l'administration culturelle et
seulement 5% des concerts sont dirigées
par des femmes
on pourrait se demander si le talent au
génie créateur serait seulement
l'apanage des hommes
selon le rapport de rennes sera publié
en 2009 à la demande du ministère de la
culture ces inégalités ont entre autres
pour conséquence le gâchis de
compétences ou des représentations
artistiques qui véhiculent des
stéréotypes
quand j'étais adjointe à la culture de
ma vie la ville dommange avait
personnellement veillé à compétence
égale les candidats sélectionnés pour
les jurys au poste de direction et bien
soit tout autant des femmes que des
hommes
ainsi je crois qu'il ne revient pas à
l'état ou aux élus d'intervenir au
niveau de l'acte artistique mais bien de
garantir un égal accès aux fonctions de
décisions et aux moyens de production et
aux réseaux de diffusion
la résolution du parlement européen de
mars 2009 sur l'égalité de traitement et
d'accès entre les hommes et les femmes
dans les arts du spectacle je cite
invite les états membres envisagent est
une première étape réalise dans la lutte
contre les inégalités dans les arts du
spectacle consistant à assurer la
présence d'au moins un tiers de
personnes du sexe minoritaire dans
toutes les branches du secteur madame la
ministre
comment envisagez-vous de faire
appliquer cette recommandation
par ailleurs en 2008 un projet d'
assises nationales pour l'égalité dans
les arts et la culture avait été avancée
ainsi qu'une charte pour l'égalité dans
les arts et la culture
je pense qu'il serait utile de les
mettre en oeuvre le savez madame la mise
tout le secteur culturel s'est récemment
mobilisé notre collègue marie christine
poulin président de notre commission de
la culture le sait bien il est
inadmissible que de telles inégalités
persistent aussi nous souhaitons
connaître votre plan d'action en la
matière merci chers collègues
madame la ministre pour la réponse merci
monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice morin desailly décidément
cette séance de questions sera
l'occasion de constater que les
stéréotypes sont partout et que les
inégalités sont partout y compris dans
un domaine en effet où on les attendait
pas particulièrement la culture
on n'imaginait peut-être plus plus
égalitaire je sais pas plus plus plus
plus en phase avec son temps
et bien non et parmi les chiffres que
vous avez cités qui sont suffisamment
parlants
j'ai envie moi aussi de rajouter celui
qui me surprend toujours à savoir que
les spectacles qui sont mises en scène
par des femmes généralement récolte des
subventions moins importante que celle
que ceux qui sont mises en scène par des
hommes un peu comme si naturellement les
femmes allaient réussir à faire des
miracles avec moins de moyens donc bien
sûr nous avons un souci est le souci est
d'autant plus important que les chiffres
n'ont pas évolué
c'est plus de 80% de directeurs
d'institutions dans le domaine du
spectacle vivant qui l'année dernière
encore étaient des hommes
comment est-ce qu'on va agir sur ce
sujet pendant tout ce mois de septembre
j'ai réuni mes collègues ministres dans
des conférences de l'égalité où nous
avons abordé politiques sectorielles par
politiques sectorielles les moyens de
faire mieux que ce que nous faisons en
faveur de l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes avec la ministre en charge de
la culture dont je tiens à souligner
vraiment l'investissement sur ce sujet
nous avons d'ores et déjà établi une
feuille de route je vous en donne un
exemple parce qu'il m'est difficile de
tout rendre public aujourd'hui mais nous
irons par exemple au delà des
obligations fixées par la loi pour
réussir à atteindre sans délai les 50%
de nomination de femmes parmi les
dirigeants des établissements publics et
les conseils d'administration histoire
d'accélérer la dynamique de rattrapage
dans toute la sphère culturelle
par ailleurs vous aurez dans les cahiers
des charges les contrats d'objectifs les
conventions avec les institutions
culturelles systématiquement une
exigence d'égalité qui sera fixée
égalité dans les rémunérations égalité
dans les nominations aux postes de
direction égalité dans la programmation
aussi et le niveau de subventions
voilà le type de mesures que nous
pouvons prendre si nous voulons créer un
choc véritable je vous remercie pour la
réplique madame catherine morin desailly
madame la ministre
merci de ces précisions j'ai insisté sur
le spectacle vivant aujourd'hui mais
j'aurais pu tout autant citer le secteur
de l'audiovisuel à ces dégâts ça me
satisfait que ce soit une femme maxine
saragosse qu'il soit nommé à la tête de
la
sous la précédente mandature nous avions
eu la nomination de véronique cayla à la
présidence d'arte et pour autant
j'aurais aimé avoir votre assurance que
vous avez évoqué les médias en réponse à
madame jouanno tout à l'heure que nous
aurons bien le maintien de cette
commission qui travaille sur l'image des
femmes présidée par michel riser suite
aux rapports aussi de brigitte grésy
qu'on est bien le maintenant de cette
commission qui travaille de manière
extrêmement précise en rassemblant
l'ensemble du secteur des médias pour
les sensibiliser à 7 à cette question je
rappelle que notre assemblée très
attentive à ce sujet puisque en 2009
lors de la loi sur la télévision
publique j'étais rapporteur du projet
j'avais proposé qu'on introduise en
préambule du texte le principe de
l'égalité des genres et nous sommes tous
ici sur ses ventes très attentif à ce
que ça puisse se mettre réellement en
avion vous remercie madame catherine
génisson pour le groupe socialiste et
apparentés vous avez la parole merci
merci monsieur le président vous ne
serez pas étonnés madame la ministre que
en ce qui me concerne je vous interroge
aussi sur le sujet de l'égalité
professionnelle ça d'ailleurs été la
priorité des questions présentées par
mes différentes collègues car le sujet
reste extrêmement prégnant est
extrêmement grave
en effet nous constatons aujourd'hui
encore à peu près 27 % au dîner
d'inégalité salariale dont 9 % sont
vraiment de la pure discrimination quand
on sait que le sujet de l' embauche ce
sujet de la mobilité le sujet de la
promotion le sujet des conditions de
travail le sujet de la formation sont
des sujets qui sont mal résolu dans le
monde de l'entreprise
ce qui aboutit bien évidemment à ce
qu'on appelle le plafond de 20 ont
planché collant comme aime le dire nos
amis et nos amis canadiens
et dire que malheureusement si cela
existe dans le monde de l'entreprise on
constate on fait le même constat dans le
monde dans les différentes fonctions
publiques
et s'ils ne se sont pas les inégalités
salariales que l'on constate ce sont des
inégalités de revenus et le plafond de
verre existe de la même façon et j'ai
envie de dire que le constat est
dramatiquement le même après plusieurs
années après plusieurs années après de
nombreuses années j'avais commis un
rapport en 2000 je crois que les
chiffres sont quasiment les mêmes
alors bien évidemment ça a été dit par
beaucoup d'entre nous le sujet doit être
traité sur le monde du travail mais il
doit être traitée aussi en amont et
j'adhère totalement aux propos de ma
collègue madame laborde sur le sujet de
l'éducation nationale quand on sait que
ce sont majoritairement des femmes qui
sont des enseignantes je crois que le
sujet mérite d'être traité de l'école
maternelle à l'enseignement supérieur
c'est également le sujet de
l'articulation des temps de vie nous
avons beaucoup parlé des descendants
parlons aussi des ascendants parce que
ce sont aussi les femmes qui gardent les
grands-parents les belles-mères les blés
beau père et je voudrais dire à ce
propos que quand on parle du sujet du
congé parental qu'il convient bien
évidemment de réformer il faut savoir
que on pourra leur forme et sur le fond
à le faire partager entre les hommes et
les femmes que si on arrive à l'égalité
salariale
car force est constater quand il ya 30 %
de différence dans un revenu le choix
est vite fait je voudrais également bien
évoqué mais ça a été évoqué par d'autres
tous les stéréotypes qui existent le
monde de la publicité les jeux enfin
tous tout ce que conclut et je sais tout
ça pour vous poser trois questions
madame lalami la première c'est de
savoir comment dans les négociations
sociales le sujet de la féminisation de
la représentativité des hommes et des
femmes est un sujet traité deuxièmement
de savoir si vous avez des mesures
spécifiques pour accompagner les
entreprises qui font des efforts
substantiels sur des plans d'égalité à
la fois delusions spécifique
individuelle des mesures plus globale et
troisièmement continue du fait que ce
sujet de l'inégalité professionnelle est
un sujet très prégnant dans notre
société ne serait-il pas opportun
d'avoir une loi cadre qui n'aboutirait
pas forcément des mesures législatives
sur chacun des sujets mais qui
permettrait de faire prendre conscience
à notre pays que ça reste un sujet
excessivement prioritaires merci madame
la ministre s'il vous plaît madame g
mission madame la sénatrice qui
connaissait parfaitement le sujet que
puis je vous apprendre peut-être vous
dire non pas revenir sur le diagnostic
mais vous dire ce que nous avons conclu
avec les partenaires sociaux au terme de
la grande conférence sociale qui nous a
un peu donné cette feuille de route que
nous mettons en application aujourd'hui
dans la liste des faiblesses et des
fragilités qui explique pourquoi malgré
la dizaine de lois que nous avons en
faveur de l'égalité professionnelle nous
avons toujours cet écart de rémunération
persistant aujourd'hui dans la liste
donc des faiblesses il en est une qui en
effet peut-être est dû à des
organisations syndicales qui ont
tellement de priorités à mettre en avant
que l'égalité professionnelle n'est pas
forcément toujours au dessus de la liste
de courses je vais le dire comme cela et
donc quand vous regardez le
fonctionnement concret des choses au
sein des entreprises les instances
représentatives du personnel ne mettent
pas forcément ce sujet dans leurs
priorités n'interpelle pas forcément
l'inspection du travail pour qu'elle
vienne faire un contrôle
comme c'est prévu dans le mécanisme
légal actuel et donc cela pose la
question de la priorisation la
hiérarchisation des priorités puis cela
pose peut-être aussi la question la
représentativité de saisir paix et du
fait que ben là encore les clips entre
les femmes et les hommes n'est pas
toujours atteint c'est un sujet dont
discuteront aussi les partenaires
sociaux dans la négociation que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure qui ai
commencé le 21 septembre
oui vous avez raison de dire que avoir
une sanction si possible effective au
dessus de la tête des entreprises c'est
important et j'en profite pour redire
que nous allons changer le décret
d'application de la loi pour que nous
ayons un dispositif de contrôle du
respect des obligations par les
entreprises de plus de 50 salariés
beaucoup plus effectif qu'il ne l'est
aujourd'hui et que et que les sanctions
tombent lorsqu'il le faut donc avoir un
dispositif répressif c'est important
mais en même temps il faut accompagner
les entreprises et en particulier les
pme car l'égalité professionnelle ne se
fait pas si simplement que cela et donc
nous les faisons nous faisons notamment
dans neuf régions expérimental que nous
avons identifiés dans lesquelles nous
allons monter des opérations comme par
exemple celle qui consiste comme nous
l'avons fait à réunir les 15 plus
grandes entreprises qui sont le plus
exemplaire en matière d'égalité
professionnelle et à leur demander de
faire un travail spécifique avec leurs
pme fournisseuses et sous traitante pour
mettre à leur disposition à la fois
l'expertisé les moyens et l'outillage qu
elles l ont su adopter pour faire
l'égalité en leur sein et dupliquer
cette démarche vers l'égalité
professionnelle dans ces pme avec
lesquels je remercie madame voilà
c'était deux exemples parmi d'autres
biens
madame génisson en un mot oui merci
madame la ministre de ses réponses il
faudrait peut-être assister sur un sujet
qui est le sujet de l'éducation
nationale est peut-être puisque nous
imposons aux entreprises produire les
rapports de situation comparée de pour
traiter du sujet de l'égalité
professionnelle peut-être pourrions-nous
demandé que soient produits dans les
conseils d'administration des rapports
de situation comparée de l'orientation
des filles et des garçons ça veut pas du
tout dire qu'il faut 50 50 dans chacune
des filières mais ça permettrait
peut-être de connaître exactement
comment se font les orientations des
filles et des garçons
au cours de leur cursus éducatif
merci la parole est maintenant madame
catherine cros cassia pour le groupe
union pour un mouvement populaire
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues
la loi du 12 mars 2012 relatives à la
précarité dans la fonction publique
consacre un volet spécifique à l'égalité
professionnelle hommes femmes
elle est entrée en vigueur le 2 mai
dernier et ce dispositif prévoit
notamment la nomination graduelle
jusqu'en 2018 de 40% de femmes aux
postes dirigeants et supérieurs des
trois fonctions publiques
la fonction d'état à la fonction
territoriale et la fonction hospitalière
des pénalités financières sont aussi
prévues qui pourrait atteindre 90 mille
euros par poste de femme qui n'aurait
pas été attribués justement à une femme
le 27 juin
un décret a renforcé ce volet législatif
en procédant à la nomination d'un haut
fonctionnaire auprès de chaque ministre
qui est chargé de veiller au bon
déroulement du processus paritaire de
ces nominations
ces mesures madame le ministre à 10 une
volonté comparable à celle du précédent
gouvernement imposer des femmes aux plus
hautes sphères publiques qui sont
actuellement majoritairement peuplé par
des hommes
elle ne représente en effet que 21 4 %
des postes de direction alors qu'elles
sont plus de 54 % de fonctionnaires
mais cette volonté est elle bien réelle
depuis m 2012 les nominations de hauts
fonctionnaires ne vont pas dans ce sens
je citerai trois exemples frappants sur
trente et une nomination de préfets 28
hommes 3 femmes sur six nominations de
recteur d'académie quatre hommes deux
femmes et enfin au sein du réseau
diplomatique
une seule femme à créditer ambassadeur
contre 8 tomes madame la ministre vous
avez évoqué votre intention de dresser
un premier bilan de ce dispositif
à la fin de 2012 je ne doute pas de
votre volonté
mais suite à ces premières nominations
je souhaite vous interroger sur ce
décalage
j'entre les mesures législatives et
réglementaires et même votre volonté
comment envisagez-vous de rétablir
l'équilibré entre ces nominations et en
avez vous les moyens monôme la ministre
madame monsieur le président merci
madame la sénatrice procas ya c'est une
question importante tranche pour moi
c'est une question importante s'il en
est que vous poser puisque partant d'un
principe simple l'état n'arrivera pas à
émettre le moindre jugement sur ce qui
se passe dans le secteur privé s'il
n'est pas exemplaire en ce sens je pense
que nous serons d'accord sur le sujet et
vous voyez quels que soient les couleurs
politiques auxquelles nous appartenons
j'estime que la loi sauvadet est une
très bonne chose
voilà donc il faut l'appliquer nous nous
sommes engagés non seulement à
l'appliquer mais à en accélérer
l'application puisque comme vous l'avez
rappelé il y avait plusieurs capté que
nous devions normalement aux termes de
cette loi atteindre les 40% seulement à
partir de 2018 40% de femmes est bien le
premier ministre a souhaité mobiliser
l'ensemble du gouvernement sur ce sujet
je vous renvoie une circulaire qu'il a
adressée à ses ministres le 23 août
dernier dans laquelle il souhaite que
l'état soit exemplaire sur les
nominations aux emplois dirigeants et
supérieur et que l'objectif minimal fixé
par la loi soient atteints avant le
terme de la mandature
donc ça signifie que il va falloir que
la parité progresse vite je ne vais pas
m'amuser à vous dire que c'est chose
facile mes interventions sont régulières
notamment s'agissant des nominations en
conseil des ministres pour
demander à ce que peut-être
l'accélération soit soit plus rapide
mais vous savez aussi bien que moi
combien les choses sont rendues
compliquées par l'absence de ce fameux
vivier sait ce qu on vous rétorque que
dans chaque administration c'est pas
faux non plus c'est à dire que certes il
faut donner des coups de pouce
particulier pour pour pour remplir les
objectifs mais en même temps il faut
penser à l'avenir et constituer un
vivier de jeunes femmes repérés comme
étant particulièrement prometteuse et
faire en sorte qu'elle puisse monter en
grade jusqu'à être au niveau n moins un
qui permettent ensuite de les voir
nommer en tout cas sachez une chose
c'est que nous avons décidé d'être très
transparent sûr sur ces questions là
puisque un suivi de ces nominations sera
réalisée chaque semestre un bilan annuel
sera présenté en conseil des ministres à
la fin de chaque année civile il sera
rendu public sur le site du gouvernement
et donc vous pourrez voir que notre
intention n'est sans doute pas qu'il y
ait simplement davantage de femmes chefs
de bureau mais qu'il y ait bien
davantage de femmes aux postes de cadres
dirigeants
merci merci madame progression on
réplique
madame la ministre vous parlez d'un
vivier faute est d'avoir un vivier mais
c'est un discours que l'on entend
politique et nous les femmes politiques
qui s'y présentent
on sait bien que quel que soit le parti
politique on nous répond toujours oui
mais il n'y a pas de femmes compétents
je ne crois pas il ya autant de femmes
qui sont diplômés de l'enseignement
supérieur dans l'administration qui dit
à des hommes n'empêche qu'on nomme des
hommes repérés vous me dites oui mais
repéré par qui on repérer par ceux qui
sont déjà à la tête et qui sont des
hommes je crois que là-dessus il
faudrait faire un effort et que ce
repérage des futurs potentialités ne
soit pas effectuée que par les hommes
qui sont déjà en fonction
sinon malgré les bonnes volontés les
choses n'avanceront pas merci cholet la
parole est maintenant à madame colette
mélot pour le groupe union pour un
mouvement populaire
monsieur le président madame la ministre
entre mes chers collègues ma question
portera sur le rôle de l'école dans les
choix d'orientation professionnelle des
filles même si nous l'avons déjà abordé
je voudrais en dire quelques mots
en effet on constate que si les jeunes
filles obtiennent de meilleurs résultats
que les garçons jusqu'au baccalauréat
elles sont ensuite moins nombreuses à
s'engager dans des filières sélectives
tels que les classes préparatoires par
exemple ou dans des études supérieures
scientifiques hausse ainsi les filles
représentent moins de 30% des effectifs
de l'école nationale d'administration
ena et 13,6 pour cent des élèves de
l'école polytechnique les formations
scientifiques quant à elle ne compte que
25 % de femmes
certes nous constatons dès le plus jeune
âge que l'engouement des filles pour
certains métiers diffèrent de ceux des
garçons mais de tels chiffres
s'expliquent surtout par des facteurs
sociaux on doit admettre qu'il ya des
modèles et qu'il y a une culture
familiale qui font que les jeunes
s'orientent vers des carrières
différentes
l'école a un rôle important à jouer pour
lutter contre cela
tout d'abord les manuels scolaires on en
a déjà parlé doivent être un outil de
transmission d'une culture de l'égalité
car c'est dès le plus jeune âge qu'il
faut combattre les idées reçues
or trop souvent les manuels renforce les
stéréotypes montre les femmes uniquement
dans la sphère familiale où cantonner à
certains métiers
il faudrait sensibiliser davantage les
enseignants à ces questions au cours de
leur formation initiale et de même les
conseillers d'orientation dans les
collèges ou lycées devraient encourager
davantage les filles à se renseigner sur
les professions considéré
traditionnellement comme masculine et
sur l'ensemble des filières du supérieur
c'est à la source que nous combattrons
lemieux l'inégalité professionnelle
persistant dans notre société
puisque le gouvernement a déclaré
engager une réforme d'ampleur de l'école
pourriez-vous nous dire madame la
ministre ce que vous envisagez de faire
ce sujet ou en tout cas le confirmer tel
que vous l'avez déjà exprimé
précédemment madame la ministre c'est à
vous
merci madame la sénatrice permettez moi
de prendre une seconde pour compléter ma
réponse précédente parce que je ne
voudrais pas qu'il y ait de malentendu
sur la notion de viviez je n'aime pas
non plus qu'on se réfugie derrière cette
expression pour ne rien faire quand on
parle de viviez on parle d'une chose
précise c'est que le moment où se
constitue les viviers de celle qui joue
ce qu'ils vont pouvoir accéder à des
postes de haute responsabilité c'est
généralement dans une carrière
professionnelle entre 30 et 40 ans entre
30 et 40 ans c'est précisément le moment
où les femmes généralement pour congé
maternité etc pour vie familiale vont
être moins présentes que les hommes dans
ces promotions et donc se poser la
question du vivier c'est faire en sorte
par exemple de revoir les règles de
promotion en différents en fonction des
postes par exemple on sait que pour
devenir préfet il faut avoir rempli
telle et telle et telle exigence avoir
eu des postes d'encadrement et c est ce
que toutes ces règles ce processus n'est
pas nuisible d'une certaine façon on ne
laisse pas les femmes qui on le sait
bien entre 30 et 40 ans se sont
peut-être un peu plus absente et que les
hommes je ne m'attarderai pas plus que
cela je vais répondre à votre question
madame la sénatrice merci de me l'avoir
posée en vous disant une chose simple
c'est que finalement prendre le sujet de
l'égalité et de la lutte contre les
stéréotypes par l'éducation nationale
c'est sans doute la meilleure façon
d'arriver à le poser de façon globale
j'évoquais tout à l'heure la formation
indispensable des enseignants
je n'ai pas assez insisté permettez moi
de le faire sur la question des
personnels d'orientation car beaucoup
d'entre vous ont évoqué l' inégale
répartition des filles et des garçons
dans les filières de métiers bien sûr
mais il n'y a t'il pas à la fois une
forme d'autocensure dans les familles
quant aux perspectives professionnelles
des filles et aussi peut-être dans les
professionnels de l'orientation un
manque de
deux discours qui viennent contrecarrer
cette autocensure et puis il ya la
question au delà de la formation des
professionnels et de la formation à
l'égalité des enfants il ya la question
de tous ces outils que les enfants ont
eu en leur possession à savoir notamment
les manuels scolaires ou encore les jeux
ludiques au plus jeune âge les manuels
scolaires sont un vrai sujet on voit
bien que au fond un certain nombre de
clichés sont véhiculés par ces manuels
alors l'état n'écrit pas les manuels
scolaires ce c'est de la responsabilité
des éditeurs que le contenu de ces
manuels mais on sait qu'on peut engager
nous n'y sommes engagés en tout cas avec
vincent peillon engagé une démarche
positive avec les éditeurs de manuels
pour leur faire prendre conscience des
difficultés qu'ils confortent avec des
images et des stéréotypes et revenir
peut-être un peu en arrière merci bien
pour la réplique
madame colette mélot merci monsieur le
président mais je voudrais vous
remercier madame la ministre pour cette
réponse qui complétait donc les
différentes propositions que vous aviez
déjà fait en tout cas oui je crois qu'il
fallait insister sur l'orientation pour
pouvoir présenter aux filles tout le
panel de deux possibilités dont elle
dispose et elle ne pense certainement
pas certaines orientations qu'il faut
leur leur montrer il faut surtout leur
montrer qu'elles sont capables de
s'orienter dans différentes dans
différentes carrières voilà je vous
remercie bien je voudrais vous remercier
mes chers collègues
c'est la fin de cette séance de
questions cribles thématiques consacrées
à l'égalité entre les hommes et les
femmes si vous souhaitez la revoir elle
est disponible en vod sur notre site
internet publicsenat.fr
très bonne fin de journée à tous